hey everyone welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel from learning
as you know on my channel i want to help
you to become successful in the first
years of your career so over the last
years one thing changed for sure and
this is that people spend much more time
in front of their desk at home than they
used to in 2019 and before but what does
this mean people are wondering how do i
equip my desk at home in the best
possible way this was surely a question
that i asked myself a lot in the last
months so today i want to show you how
my desk setup looks like at a c level
executive at a german startup and also
has a content producer here of course
for youtube and is someone who thought a
lot about how to conduct great and
optimal video conferences so let me show
you around here in my little content
room a little paradise here at home and
let's do it so the big challenge that
i'm facing is that we are here in munich
which means apartment prices are quite
high also we don't have a huge apartment
here so it's limited space we have this
little room here that i use for content
creation and for work in general which
of course puts me in a bit of a tough
spot that i need to make this mighty
functional so we just have a simple
cabinet to stow away some stuff what you
see here is my silver play button my
silver youtube play button so for the
uninitiated once you pass 100 000
subscribers on youtube youtube sends you
this nice little thing here so pretty
cool indeed quite proud of it i must say
i think the next one that you get is
only for one million subscribers then
you get a bigger one in gold so still a
long way to go thanks again for everyone
who subscribes who supports the channel
but now let's maybe get really to the
core to the center of this room and this
is of course here my desk and i will
show you all the individual pieces in a
moment go more into detail of all of
this probably the thing that you would
already notice this year or this sound
proving material at the wall
so as you can imagine this took quite a
lot of discussions with my wife for her
to allow me to put all of this here on
the wall given that yeah again we don't
have that many rooms here in the
apartment so it's now quite a
significant part of the flat
the reason that it did there is just
that there was quite a lot of echo quite
a lot of reverb here in the room which
is of course not great for two reasons
first obviously for creating videos but
also in video conferences
so i don't know how you feel it but i
always dark you notice that whenever i'm
in a video conference with someone else
and lots of reverb lots of echo in the
room really not a great experience
especially if you sit together in a
longer meeting so this really helps
frankly there's still quite a problem
with a reverb in this room so this
improved but not solved it so that's the
soundproofing thing then you hear of
course see the two lights again two
things two purposes i do many videos
where i just sit here in front of my
desk and just create a video with the
camera here directly pointed towards me
of course lighting is really one of the
most important things when creating
videos by the way most of the products
that i will show you i will include
links to them in the video description
so feel free to just check them out if
you feel like this is something that
might be relevant to you as way so i
will show you more in detail on what
exactly i have here on my desk in a
moment let me just quickly finish by
showing you the rest of the room because
indeed what you have here to my left is
this little cabinet with the tv and then
of course lots of room here to stow away
things so here you just have all my
audio equipment and actually also gimbal
here you have my old camera that served
me very well on my first year on youtube
here are some additional lenses for my
camera and here's some other more or
less gimmicky equipment that i use for
this so definitely some some great
room and things that i use here
this is one of the big things that i'm
just not really sure about what to make
use it what to use here of course this
light is just here for the purpose of
this video to better light out the room
this is not usually here what you see
here is this big empty white wall
what do i do with this wall please let
me know in the comments give me some
suggestions this is the wall directly
opposing my desk so the wall that is
often in the background when i create a
youtube video and of course it looks a
little bit boring right so i could
probably do some cool stuff with that i
was thinking about doing some additional
putting some additional soundproofing
material here so this would be one
option but then of course maybe not the
best aesthetics if you have some great
ideas just let me know
and then of course last but not least
here this section with this couch and
also this background here um
one thing that i am thinking about is
potentially to take away this little
thing here and maybe put a firm learning
sign in neon lights so some like
lighting installation that says from
learning here in the back because this
would then potentially allow me to do
some video scenes where i stand here
with this as a background trust this
might actually be quite a nice
background then if there's a nice from
learning thing here in the back let me
know what you think potentially this
could also be a nice podcast setup so
i'm thinking about maybe at some point
in the future to start a podcast then i
could sit here maybe with some guests
from learning in the back maybe a little
table
just some ideas but let me know what you
think about that in the comments but now
given that the focus of this video is my
desk setup let me show you exactly that
and probably the the key piece here is
surely the display the monitor so i was
looking for an ultra-wide monitor i
believe this monitor has
38 yes 38 inches so quite a big thing i
wanted a very big one frankly when i
ordered it i expected that it's so big
that it might even be too much
um if i now think back at it probably
also wouldn't have heard if it would
have been even a little bit larger so
for me this size is surely not too large
so surely not too wide let's put it this
way and of course the funniest thing is
the the packaging that this came in so
let's see if i i find it in here
so this is the packaging of the two
lights that were behind my desk
[Music]
so look at this beauty this is quite a
package i guess it's also still pretty
heavy even though the monitor was taken
out of it so this is what you can expect
if you order it i will link it in the
video description i'm very satisfied and
happy with the quality very an excellent
display check it out if this is
something that
you feel like you would like to have but
now back to the desks another thing that
i got and actually like quite a lot is
this mouse this is the logitech mx
master
3. so it's a mouse that i feel like at
the moment a lot of people are getting
and i can understand why so i saw it
also with some other youtubers who got
this
i think one of the greatest things is
really the scroll wheel which has also
two scroll reads here so just check it
out try it out it's really a cool mouse
which also helps a lot when you edit
video for instance because then you can
do some horizontal scroll on the
premiere pro timeline so for those
people interested in things like this
this is quite handy
another thing that i have here is just a
nice log attack keyboard
so i thought that the wire wouldn't
disturb me too much
frankly now it does so i mean obviously
you do your own choices but if i would
now get a new one probably i wouldn't
get one with a wire anymore but again i
will link all these things in the video
description in case you are interested
in them
and then what you see here is also my
laptops of quite a bunch of laptops that
are circulated this is now my work
laptop so it's a classical thinkpad x1 i
will also link the model that i have in
the video description in case you're
interested to check it out another thing
that i use quite a lot frankly not even
so much for my video productions because
there i use distinct microphones for the
cameras but what i use quite a lot for
my video conferences is this one this is
a blue 80 usb mic what's great is that
it's really just port by usb so you just
stick it in the computer and it's plug
and play so no complex audio interfaces
or anything like that
and this gives quite good sound also for
a pretty decent price for what this is
costing you so if you are doing lots of
video conferences and want to make sure
that your sound your audio is very good
can very much recommend you to get a mic
like this obviously then what you need
are some headphones so often i just use
airport pro so apple airport pros to get
this done as well because otherwise you
might have some some some reverb also in
the audio some disturbances but this one
a really great thing and then last but
not least are some speakers that i have
here so these are the audio engine i
believe a2 plus or something like this
what they're called again i will link
this to you as well if you're interested
in that
check them out i think also pretty good
sound i just got annoyed over time
because in the beginning i always had
the sound just via the laptop which of
course is not the best experience and
then it's also just like coming from one
corner of the table just over time this
disturbed me quite a lot of course also
for video editing but just for general
uh desktop browsing experience so this
investment definitely paid off just to
provide a proper
sound experience here then the next
thing that i use is uh the camera of
course this is really my main camera
that i also use for youtube it's a sony
a7s
iii so frankly quite an expensive one so
i wouldn't use it just for regular use
if you don't have a proper purpose for
it nevertheless i will also link this
model here but what i do also use it for
are video conferences so you can connect
your camera to the pc and then use it as
a webcam if you like really for your
video conferences this really gives just
a superb image it's really standing out
i can especially recommend this to you
if you
just you do lots of video conferences in
general maybe you even work in sales
conduct lots of sales calls surely a
camera like this of this quality is not
needed but if you are willing to invest
500 maybe a thousand euros so in a great
camera this will really make a
difference you will really stand out in
all these video conferences to connect
this to the pc i have a little
gadget it's an elgato cam link 4k that i
use in theory i could even do a video
conferences in 4k with this obviously
this would be a little bit of an
overkill as you can see the camera is
not standing on a standby himself but
this is a so-called
gorilla pod that you can screw this in
so you can use this also to put other
kinds of cameras on top of it all kinds
of little devices mobile devices so
pretty handy just you can flexibly
rearrange it depending on what you need
what you see here in the back is a
little dock i got the thinkpad dock that
i use really to just have one cable that
goes into the laptop to connect the
laptop to the whole setup this is of
course very handy you just want to take
the laptop put it in your bag go to your
office and then in the evening come back
if you are working in the office plug it
back in and all runs you don't need to
connect lots and lots of cables to the
laptop this is definitely your changer
and then you want to see here also is
my phone obviously i have a
smartphone and iphone not the newest one
it's an old one that i
purchased from my sister so i believe
this is an iphone x so i think already
like four or five years old so my sister
got an upgrade and then she sold me her
old phone and now i'm using it and i'm
feeling quite okay with it and here i
have an induction charging device where
i just put this on i can also use this
to charge the airport pros last but not
least maybe let's quickly also talk
about the chair this is actually quite a
nice chair it's pretty old so i have it
since high school so over 10 years old i
know that at that time it was really a
good one so it wasn't
super cheap but it definitely was worth
it given that i'm still using it today
frank i don't know anymore where it's
from or how i got it but very nice comfy
chair can definitely recommend you to
get some of this as well because in
front of the desk you just will spend
many many hours usually and it's
definitely a difference so to sum up i
think nothing too crazy what is really
making a difference for me is first the
display having a big display with lots
of screen estate screen real estate here
second proper camera and proper
microphone for your video conferences
this is not only helpful for producing
videos but for producing content in
general and last but not least some
proper lighting again also for your
video conferences this will make a good
difference and will make you look much
more professional then maybe you will
just have it if you just use a laptop
and then the built-in camera in the
laptop of course you don't need these
professional great things simpler
devices than the one that i showed you
that i will link below will definitely
suffice but look at this trust that will
make a difference for you as well so i
hope you found this insightful
potentially also took away some
inspirations for your setup at home let
me know in the comments what you think
about the things that i showed you today
of course if you took any value out of
this video at all please hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to stay up to date on all
my content big big thank you to all the
members supporting this channel my name
is heinrich i release videos every
single saturday see you again next week
until then all best and bye